le rapport de l'organisation des nations
unies est accablant cette attaque
aérienne a touché la ville de bounty et
coûté la vie à 19 civils réunis pour un
mariage un constat bien éloignée de la
version française qui affirmait
jusqu'ici avoir uniquement ciblé des
jihadistes l' enquête réalisée par la
mission multi dimensionnelle intégré des
nations unies pour la stabilisation mali
est formel cette frappe n'avait rien de
légal au regard du droit international
la mine où cela est en mesure de
confirmer la tenue d'une célébration de
mariages qui a rassemblé sur le lieu de
la frappe
une centaine de civils parmi lesquels se
trouvaient cinq personnes armés membres
présumés de la katiba serma le groupe
touchés étaient très majoritairement
composées de civils qui sont des
personnes protégées contre les attaques
au regard du droit international
humanitaire
selon le rapport dix neuf personnes ont
été tuées sur le coup et trois autres
ont succombé lors de leur évacuation
parmi les vingt-deux victimes seulement
proie faisait partie de la katiba serma
organisations affiliées au groupe de
soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans
malgré les accusations le ministère
français des armées maintient sa version
le ministère français des armées
maintien avec constance et réaffirme
avec force que le 3 janvier les forces
armées françaises ont effectué une
frappe aérienne
c'est blanc un groupe armé terroriste
identifiés comme tels et aimé de
nombreuses réserves quant à la
méthodologie retenue et ne peut
considérer que ce rapport apporte une
quelconque preuve contredisant les faits
tels que décrits par les forces armées
françaises
désormais la minus ma demande aux
autorités maliennes et françaises de
diligenter une enquête qui soit je cite
indépendantes crédibles et transparentes
l'instance préconise aussi d'examiner
les processus préalable aux frappes
voire de les modifier
elle recommande également aux deux
parties d'établir les responsabilités
afin d'octroyer une réparation aux
victimes et à leurs proches
mais pour cela encore faut-il que paris
reconnaît une bavure